we're faced with the indefinite integral
of x plus three times x minus one to the
fifth dx
now we could solve this by literally
multiplying out what x minus one of the
fifth is maybe using the binomial
theorem that would take a while and then
we'd multiply that times x plus 3 and
we'd end up with some polynomial and we
could take the anti-derivative that way
or we could maybe make a substitution
here that could simplify this expression
here make it something that's a little
bit easier to take the anti-derivative
of and this isn't going to be kind of
the more traditional u substitution
where we just set u equal to something
and see if its derivative is there but
it's a kind of a form of u substitution
where we do set u equal to something and
see if it simplifies our expression in a
way that i guess simplifies it so let's
try things out
so we have this x minus 1 to the fifth
that would be a pain to expand out it
would be nice if this was just a u to
the fifth so let's just set this
let's just set this to be equal to u so
let's set u
is equal to x minus 1 and in that case d
u
is equal to
dx we could write d u dx
is equal to 1 derivative of x derivative
of negative one is just zero and these
two
these two are completely equivalent
statements and so if we did that how
could we rewrite this entire expression
well it would be equal to
the integral of
well we have x plus 3 right over here
this is neither just u
nor is it d u
so let's think about how what we could
do here well we could say if u is equal
to x minus 1 if u is equal to x minus 1
we could add 1 to both sides of this
equation and we could say u
plus 1 is equal to x
and so for x we can substitute that with
u plus 1. so let's do that so we're kind
of back substituting in for x so x is
equal to u plus 1
x is equal to u plus 1. and i'm just
trying to see if i can do something to
simplify this expression so x is u plus
x is u plus 1 then we have our plus 3
there
plus 3
times
x minus 1 to the fifth x minus 1 was u
that's the simplification we wanted to
make so times u
to the fifth power and dx is the same
thing as d u so d
u
now did this get us anywhere can we
simplify this to a form that's easy to
take the anti-derivative of
well it looks like it did let's see we
can rewrite this
as
this expression right over here is just
u plus four
so it's u
plus four
times u to the fifth
times u to the fifth i'll do it all in
one color now
d u and the reason why this simplified
thing is the the the way to simplify
things is
taking x minus one to the fifth that
would be a really hard thing to expand
but u to the fifth is just u to the
fifth and then it just changes x plus
three into a u plus four which is still
a pretty straightforward expression and
now we can just distribute the u to the
fifth
so we are left with
u to the sixth power plus four
plus four
u to the fifth
d u and this is a pretty straightforward
thing to take the anti-derivative of now
you might be saying hey sal how would
you know this was how did you know to
set u equal to be that and often times
with integration it's going to take a
little bit of trial and error there's a
certain bit of an art to it but here the
realization was well yes x minus 1 to
the fifth it could be really complicated
maybe u to the fifth might make a little
bit simpler and that did just happen to
work you could have tried u is equal to
x plus 3 but it wouldn't have simplified
it as nicely as u equal to x minus 1 did
but let's finish with this and this
integral right over here so this is
going to be equal to the anti-derivative
of u to the sixth well that's just u to
the seventh
over seven
plus the anti-derivative of u to the
fifth that's u to the sixth over six but
we have the four out here so it's four
times u to the sixth
over six and then we have a plus c and
this the we the four six is the same
thing as two
so we can rewrite this whole thing is
equal to u to the seventh
over seven plus two-thirds
u to the sixth
plus c and now we just have to undo our
u-substitution u is equal to x minus 1.
so this is going to be equal to
x minus 1 to the 7th over 7
plus
2 thirds times x minus 1 to the sixth
c and we're all done we were able to
take a fairly
hairy
or what could have been a hairy thing if
we had to expand this out
and we were able to take the
antiderivative by doing a little bit of
this u substitution and u back
substitution